[Music]
thank you
reading but also I feel like the show
knew exactly what it was doing pulling
this obscure quote and I will not thank
it for turning me on to the second
sympathetic cannibal story I've been
subjected to this year strange usually
my dreams the creamer the opposite of a
nightmare they actually shoot I mean
turn out quite Pleasant using snoozy as
your app's brand name when I'm getting
sheepy was right there for the taking
Rick clearly went to the Michael Myers
School of sit-ups and no amount of rock
hard ABS will fix that kind of lower
back drama Jerry appears to serve
everyone from a batch of pre-buttered
pancakes but why does Summers appear to
be unpre-buttered to Jerry only
pre-butter the ones beneath Summers why
what's this pancakes sold also those
pancakes have had syrup sitting on them
for who knows how long you never syrup
another man's pancakes without their
permission guys Rick should not be sold
on this not at all also also Jerry's
decided to serve up Rick's pancakes even
though he hasn't arrived yet while
summer is presumably just sitting there
watching everyone eat this is exactly
why no one wants you around Jerry also
the third where even is is the syrup
there doesn't seem to be any on the
table so did Jerry pre-syrup the first
batch if so why is this second batch of
Pancakes only pre-buttered and not
pre-syruped and where did Summer's
unpre-served and unpre buttered pancakes
come from that's it I'm setting up a
separate sin counter for this show
specifically for breakfast since best
investment I've ever made this family of
sociopath didn't even Flinch at a glass
of orange juice being spilled all over
the table when this happens in my house
the resulting reaction invariably causes
more damage than the initial spilling no
go on say it say what I don't know what
you're talking about kids you can poke
all the fingers I got if I get abs like
Rick I'm just gonna assume that this
gadget is doing some internal Switcheroo
that means it isn't poking everyone with
the same quickly disease needle but I
will be sending the show for not
confirming that assumption judging by
the brown edges here these eggs are
getting close to being overcooked and
yet more Morty butter is being added
suggesting the egg cooking is not
complete why does this show hate me I
also like Tori Amos reading the words I
like Tori Amos in a condescending manner
you take that back summer you you you
Cornflake Girl Who Wants
answering a question with a trumpet how
the hell does this discount severancing
even work their bodies are still getting
up at night and Performing many tasks so
how would everyone not wake up sore and
tired from the previous night's
activities all I'm saying is that if a
fancy machine is causing me to wake up
satisfied yet sore I want to remember it
also why would he be doing laundry in
the dark you wouldn't be able to
separate out the colors darks and whites
as well if anyone ends up with red
clothes that were previously white they
have no one to blame but themselves
pow no notes well Rick I do have notes
like why is the power chord Madness
extended to the garage door why is it
plugged all the way into the bottomless
most Outlet causing whatever this plug
leads to over stretching itself into an
unnecessarily higher position nope not
gonna let that one slide even if it is a
joke you cannot be over 100
indestructible unless of course any
attempted destruction actually resulted
in an increase of indestructibility by
10 or an increase of mass by 10 percent
as a result of this misbranding you will
see a roughly 10 increase in sins seems
like you spent an awful lot of energy
just to not give the Knight family what
they want Jerry would be no notes at TV
sins why won't you rinse your dishes
counter question why are your eyeballs
glowing like you have a thousand watt
bulb inserted into your cavities once
again we do not need to see anyone
puking ever I don't care if it's
animated we don't need to see it stop
showing it the [ __ ] your problem with
me not already knowing the answer to
this question after just bursting into
your granddaughter's room without
permission while she's sleeping Rick's
lucky wasn't greeted with a high
velocity radio alarm clock to the jaw or
whatever it is the teenagers sleep
through nowadays did you have to make
mushy garbage science on the living room
carpet if this has been pulled from the
garbage I'm very confused putting aside
the fact that an entire box of eggs has
been thrown away what even happened to
them did a wild fox just very politely
nibble on the top half of these knowing
that Rick would need them for some Wild
Eggs Machina either way I'm still
counting this as a breakfast sin aren't
they going to be suspicious seeing night
summer covered in all this Terry Gilliam
two episodes ago summer said she didn't
know anything about die hard but we're
supposed to believe now that she has
enough knowledge of Terry Gilliam to
make this kind of reference you were
souping up that some nem you whatever so
they could extend its range beyond the
house I'm guessing the plan here is
global Domination by creating an army of
night people but if it currently only
covers the house and night Rick has only
managed to extend the range by 169
percent nice then that's really only
going to cover the neighboring house and
maybe 70 of the next one at most I
really don't think Derek needs to be
worrying at this point Sorry Rick but
your opinion means very little to me
wait how did night summer manage to fake
being regular summer are the veiny
eyeballs and husky speech just a choice
how the hell is she just switching that
[ __ ] on and off
everyone get behind my app
this [ __ ] show man okay somebody
really needs to dial in the dosage on
these darts it should not take this many
darts unless the dosage is homeopathic
or the end goal is a [ __ ] coma I'm a
friend of your son in law expecting us
to believe that Jerry would be able to
make a friend yep that joke's exactly as
mean as you think it is Rick just had to
slap night Jerry to get him to turn back
to Day Jerry but night summer flies
several feet and lands in these boxes
without reverting back to day summer
that is some night time slash daytime
[ __ ] I know this is a fun visual gag
but what Maniac is selling cardboard
boxes in the middle of the night that
are fully assembled fully assembled who
buys cardboard boxes fully assembled ew
almost didn't make it choosing to peel
through metal instead of oh I don't know
shooting through the already smashed
window
the day and night family survived this
let's go home right grandpa great idea
summer rolling the credits here makes it
seem as if the show wants this to feel
like the end of Rick and Morty as we
know it what's weird is that the
post-credits scene is super long and
undoes all of that which kind of just
makes it a scene scene and now I feel
like I've been tricked into hanging
around for the credits which I didn't
pay attention to anyway because it was
so obvious that the story wasn't over
yet so the bottom line for me is that if
you want to make a big swing with your
TV show start by getting breakfast right
first normally this would have been
dealt with by our day monoid oppressors
the Knight family scheme falls apart
because they apparently aren't smart
enough to keep their jobs budget their
finances or do [ __ ] laundry which is
beyond baffling considering this isn't
nearly as complicated as half of the
[ __ ] that they were being asked to do in
the first place wasn't the whole point
that they get the mundane done so the
Day family can be the Mindless zombies
how long have we been asleep oh it can't
be that long
oh my God no they killed the Choco Taco
Time to update my weekly list of crazy I
have to say because of Rick and Morty
with using a sweet flavor Taco as a unit
of time measurement
with insomnia nothing's real been having
him do crunches while I sleep
speak English who wants cake
I'm sorry Dave I'm afraid I can't do
that
but get back to my story I had like two
of those seven layer burritos let's just
say they didn't schedule any bathroom
breaks in the middle of my nieces
christening why are you wearing that
suit why are you wearing that stupid man
suit that's fair
hit this [ __ ] statement noise
[Music]
is too much